[Music]
whoa it's eleven dollars
looking forward to the day oh good luck
where's zippy let's play zippy
control f zippy
zip oh zippy
ah i found zippy oh the most recent
challenge
good luck zippy never played before
oh also things pie hole subbing for 19
months
[Music]
oh let's play gambit against zippy the
england
gambit of greatness oh
opponent doesn't want to take a free
pawn
so there's there's a funny line after 95
oh opponent doesn't do it
i have a funny story after this game
i'll have to share
let's play this
hey is toggy here or no people just
using the taggy emotes
and the taki command
your my badgers will come for you
what is a badger it's like an animal
it's like a beaver
wait or is it like a platypus
wasn't like free oh no oh no
i saw the knight was defended i was so
fixated on on moving
or making the light move to a sad place
[Music]
ah
okay so i'm not winning immediately
the position is still good though i
think i should take
just have more more possibilities in the
center
[Music]
yeah it's too fixated on what a badger
is
this is pleasant
my queen is really doesn't have too many
squares
okay let's look up what the badger looks
like
oh it's like a raccoon
or it's the same color as a raccoon
but it's huh
it's a badger
wait that's not a raccoon what is this
it's like a combination of a raccoon and
a possum
kind of
or a beaver and a platypus
oh it's kind of beaver-like huh
i thought it's like a sports team too
honey badger don't give a
what honey badger
oh
wait what's the difference between a
badger and a honey badger
[Music]
alexa what's the difference between a
badger and a honey badger
this might answer your question
according to wikipedia
badgers are short-legged omnivores in
the family's muscelity
and method today badgers are a
polyphyletic grouping
and are not a natural taxonomic grouping
badgers are united by their squat bodies
adapted for fossorial activity all
belong to the caniform sub-order of
carnivore and mammals.the honey badger
also known as the rottle is a mammal
widely distributed in africa
southwest asia and the indian
subcontinent
because of its wide range and occurrence
in a variety of habitats
it is listed as least concern on the you
can red list
it is the only species in the genus
mallivera and in the mystelic subfamily
malibuny
alexa go on
[Music]
oh no my queen's on the darkest day got
me feeling some kind of way
alexa quiet
[Music]
alexa stop it
wow sanders core strife redeemed hello
oh hello to sir strife
wow triple fork leads to queen sacks
mother mate
hope youtube doesn't copyright me for
that
we got some interesting badger facts got
some nice triple fork
got unexpected despacito
i don't know how we'll edit it but i'll
have to find some copyright for you
my oh my what a wonderful mate oh yeah
oh yeah zippy zippity
so jan kristoff do the
should have a son and
name him zipity
and then that would be zippity-doo-dah
that'd be nice
[Music]
oh yeah the one thing i wanted to
share about this game so
so knight f3 e4 there's a move here
knight e5
look at this look at this this is the
england gambit
declined reversed nikoli mamembe
whatever that means
it's a long opening variation
i thought there is some longer name
though wait let me google this
[Music]
it's been played oh wow it's been
playing over over ten thousand times
oh yeah so if you look on chess.com
just.com will say
england gambit declined reverse alakine
reverse krebs
reverse makole memebe variation
it's probably more difficult to like
learn the name of the opening than to
learn
the opening itself
[Music]
anyway
if that goes on youtube hello to youtube
i don't know if that was the most
instructive video but hopefully it was
enlightening yeah a lot of things
happened that game
i missed a chance to win the night
and then white's still probably doing
okay oh never mind
starfish doesn't think so yeah because
there's no way to actually defend the
knight here
you could try this but then there's a
fight as reverse i thought we were
playing
chess not to know
what oh uno oh i haven't played uno in a
while
i should stream uno